plot
the destructive biodiversity made of
parasites
diseases viral diseases fungal diseases
bacterial diseases
predators
birds rats
worms
caterpillars
all kinds of agricultural plagues and
competitors such as other plants
which decrease the yields of cultivated
crops
now the wide diversity of attackers
which are illustrated here
we have the uh fruit worm on maize
nematodes on bananas
diseases on sugarcane
drosophila being attacked by
ants on monk fruit
mango fruit and also white worms
attacking the roots of maize a disease
on cocoa
plants all these
aggressors attackers are a problem for
agriculture and farmers
and
they account for
a huge potential loss or even observed
loss
this table
shows you the various types of attackers
of fungi bacteria viruses
animals uh other plants and the losses
potential losses are huge the total
decrease of production due to these four
categories of attackers may reach 67
percent two-thirds of the crop may be
lost
versus the situation a similar situation
without the attackers now agriculture
for a long time has focused on how to
best control or even eliminate the
attackers
at the bottom on the bottom line we see
the efficacy of a possible fight against
attackers in percentage we never will be
able to eradicate the attackers limiting
the yield of crops but we
have
ways
to reduce the attack
in modern agriculture however
the best way consists in using or the
most efficient ways consisting using
biocides pesticides
targeting this or that attacker
industrial agriculture
and agriculture
in the green revolution countries
intensive
intensive single species with a
high use of fertilizers
invest a lot in pesticides
and use
huge quantities of
fungicides
pesticides
the chemical turnover represents 40
billion dollars in this field so it's a
huge cost
for agriculture to
try and eliminate or mitigate the action
of parasites
there is a paradigm on which uh
agricultural
production is based
it's all about eradication an attacker
is an emitting factor it decreases the
yield we use a buyer site to try and
eliminate the attackers
but by doing this we forget about the
wealth of ecosystemic services
present both in the cultivated plot and
all around the cultivated plot i think
it is high time we thought about other
ways to fight against parasites and
attackers because
abundant use of pesticides obviously has
a negative negative impact
on both the
producers and farmers health on the
consumer's health
we have reason to worry
about the use of pesticides by farmers
especially in
developing countries where safety rules
are not really complied with
we have a huge public health problem
and obviously pesticides leave residues
on the produce
whereby the consumers are also in danger
and the whole ecosystem is in danger
toxicology of the pesticides
in the environment is really a source of
worry
physiology
the man who invented ddt and got the
nobel prize about 18 years ago
and ever since we have come a long way
to understand that it's now absolutely
necessary to limit the use of pesticides
which aims at dividing by two the use of
pesticides within a few years time is
being implemented it's in progress
except it's very difficult to control
the pests and attackers differently
research produces all of the uh
agricultural industry of looking for new
ways to control pesticides and attackers
and diseases
there is a very good example
of a new way
to achieve this result the use of
vegetal biodiversity present on the
plant and around the plot on the
left-hand side you see agrochemistry
everything used by industrial
agriculture to get rid of
attackers mainly pesticides
the efficacy is specific it limits
the efficacy of bio attackers for one
campaign maybe two campaigns or three
until the bio attacker finds a way to
resist the pesticide and develops
resistance but it also has an impact on
production and yield
is high
except that an excessive use of
pesticides may lead to a very
unfavorable situation
in central america require 50 60 70.
treatments
a year almost once a week an airplane
has to spread pesticides on the
plantation
you can imagine the problem with this
entails on the right hand side we have
ways to fight
impact on human health and environmental
health
with different methods than spreading
poisons in the environment
this can be achieved
through beneficial organisms
which fight
the attackers or parasitoids or
parasites or pests which attack the
original pests
and this also will have a
beneficial effect on
soil fertility and biological activity
in the soil and finally there are some
spectacular effects on
economy and yield
with this new way to eliminate attackers
i'll give you one example
on how to use a vegetal diversity in
order to get rid of a
pest that attacks a maze in africa this
system was developed by icp in africa
it's called the push-pull system push as
in pushing pull as in pulling attracting
there is a type of muff and uh worm that
attacks maize and may reduce by 60
crop yield
now this muff
fruit
and destroys the maze the system is a
push-pull system whereby all around the
plot
a plant will be
planted simply to provide the service it
attracts
the female moss looking for a place to
lay their eggs
and this plant is toxic for the female
moth the moth deposits its uh eggs
on this
type of grass
and uh the eggs will not develop they'll
be intoxicated that this is the pool
system attracting the moss and in order
to reinforce the system between the
stocks of maize this medium is planted
and this medium is a plant that
pushes away the female moss and
therefore the moth population
looking for a place to lay their eggs
are pushed away by this plant they don't
like it this is a very simple
relatively um
cheap system to push away the
parasite out of the plot attracting it
outside of the plot to eliminate it with
a toxic
there are other advantages because the
dysmodium planted between the uh
stocks is a leguminous plant which is
going to provide nitrogen and fertilize
the soil
have an allelopathic effect on striga
seeds striker is a plant which is a
parasite for maize
and this medium will kill this trigger
see when they germinate
so it's a
way to engineer biodiversity in order to
control a parasite moth or fruit worm
and this system is now being used by
tens of
thousands of producers and farmers in
africa
this family of systems this push-pull
system
has been adapted
in other systems
a system that allows to push away the
parasites and attract them to a
different place between a trap where
they will be naturally eliminated was it
developed by sierra and for
adequate
companies or farms
and this way to fight parasites is
accessible for small producers
relatively cheap
and it doesn't have a negative impact on
the environment
we are finally realizing that
we don't need to think in terms of a
prescriptive way to eliminate parasites
with a pesticide same way that a
pharmacist or a doctor would
make a diagnosis and give you a uh
prescription to go and buy the drug now
we have to rethink the whole system
and there are other such like examples
the biological
fights against the pests extraction of
natural substances for some products in
order to spread them on the
cultivated plants and even uh
plants that sanitize the environment i
remember i told you about the banana
well in order to fight
against
nematode and weevil in the station there
is a plant that will limit nematodes and
limit the weevil populations and that
will go from 15 20 year treatments on
the
french west indies on banana plantations
and divide the number of uh treatments
by three
this is better for the consumers better
for the producers
and obviously it's also a better way and
a more economic way to fight attackers
you